just magnificent I don't know what to
say
this is sint-niklaas church in horn horn
horn Smith has tracked a part of his own
family history to this small town east
of Hamburg it's a moment he's a long
been waiting for he's finally sitting
where an ancestor of his played the
organ nearly 200 years ago to sit up at
the old villain to touch the keys to to
sit on the seat and just to see the view
that he saw every Sunday his mind
blowing in 1819 born Smith's great great
great grandfather August Friedrich who
took up his post here as organist and
teacher porn Smith and his wife Noel
have come to Germany from Australia a
local historian had already sifted
through church documents for references
to his ancestors among them is a
transcription of pages from the
baptismal records Hulk yeah organist
aundrea Ben Schneider is a genealogist
she's been helping with the research and
even accompanied the Smiths to other
locations around northern Germany has
been a woman
the way leads along tree-lined roads
across the Northern Plains to huts a bog
a well-known Spartan in the midst of a
lake
another of Vaughn Smith's ancestors was
born here
and the adventure neither has helped
many people research their family trees
doddridge destroyed jean yao and a
buncha gosh Easter hat on the sofa la
piscina im sue starting up as a white
Langer before Stevie Wonder's lender yet
ski cap beside him avi era tu 9m nur
under the leg long and rich fan andaz
mosman high twisting bullying devo ke
Anubis Augusta's under some help my sins
for whom via contact here dad would have
got their nest as we inhale born Smith
visits the hut sabor Cathedral his
ancestor a certain to have been inside
this Romanesque brick church the journey
into the past continues the next stop is
the little town of 17 on lectures e von
Smith's great-great-great grandmother
lived here
Turrentine is known for its abbey church
the abbey ruins and a nearly seven
hundred year old linden tree a foreign
country suddenly feels a bit more like
home I love the buildings you know i
love the homes in the roads getting used
to cobble stones what do you think I I
love the countryside the greenery of it
compared to Australia the whole
different nature of the vegetation and
how it all fits together and the homes
just look so picturesque my guess that's
a lovely without the lands flat it is
picturesque and really beautiful to look
at embassy the Australian couples
journey across northern Germany ends in
Hamburg here they visit the balanced at
immigration museum it's housed in the
very same halls tens of thousands of
Germans passed through from 1901 onward
on their way to new lives overseas
the museum includes a research center
where anyone can go through the
passenger lists looking for clues to
their family's history
you
vorn Smith draws a blank but he knows
that one of his ancestors went to
England probably from Hamburg so now the
couple are off to England